une mentalité de guerre froide c'est ce
que dénonce moscou et pékin dans une
tribune conjointe de leur ambassadeur
aux états unis et cela concerne le
sommet virtuel pour à la démocratie
organisé par le président américain joe
biden les 9 et 10 décembre prochain les
détails avec notre correspondante à
moscou maylis des stryges
dans une tribune conjointe publiée ce
vendredi dans la revue américaine the
national interest les ambassadeurs
chinois et russes à washington reproche
aux états unis d'exclure leurs pays du
sommet virtuel pour la démocratie que le
président joe biden organisera les 9 et
10 décembre prochain selon les armes
baladeur en s'arrogeant le droit de
définir qui est un pays démocratique et
qui n'est pas éligible à ce statut les
etats unis font preuve les mentalité de
guerre froide celle-ci ravivera je cite
la confrontation idéologique et les
fractures mondiale tout en créant de
nouvelles lignes de divisions
les diplomates rejette l'idée d'un
modèle unique de démocratie écoutez la
paix le développement l'équité la
justice la démocratie et la liberté sont
des valeurs communes de l'humanité la
démocratie n'est pas la prérogative dans
certains pays où d'un groupe de pays
meilleurs droits universels de tous les
peuples il peut être concrétisé de
plusieurs façons nuls modèle ne peut
convenir à tous les pays le succès du
modèle emprunté par un pays dépend de sa
capacité à répondre aux réalités du pays
à suivre la tendance de l'époque et à
favoriser le développement économique la
stabilité sociale et le progrès ainsi qu
assurer une vie meilleure pour la
population il nous ambassadeurs appelle
les autres pays à respecter la charte
des nations unies à ne pas s'ingérer
dans les affaires intérieures d'autres
états sous prétexte de lutter contre la
corruption de promouvoir les valeurs
démocratiques ou encore de protéger les
droits humains il y a suffisamment de
guerres et de troubles dans le monde
pour prouver que la propagation de la
démocratie de son système politique et
de ses valeurs par opposition à celle
des autres pays sapera gravement la paix
la sécurité la stabilité régionale et
internationale les bombardements de la
yougoslavie les interventions militaires
en irak en afghanistan et en libye
et la transformation démocratique ne
font que nuire il faudrait que les pays
se focalise sur la bonne gestion de
leurs propres affaires sont critiqués
les autres de manière condescendante
nul besoin de s'inquiéter pour la
démocratie en russie et en chine
certains gouvernements étrangers ferait
mieux de penser à eux mêmes et à ce qui
se passe chez eux est ce la liberté
qu'en divers rassemblements dans leur
pays sont dispersées à coups de balles
en caoutchouc et de gaz lacrymogènes
cela ne ressemble pas beaucoup à la
liberté les ambassadeurs russes et
chinois font ainsi écho aux critiques
formulées à moscou et à pékin après
l'annonce le 23 novembre de la centaine
de pays conviés au sommet pour la
démocratie le porte parole du président
russe dmitri peskov avait ainsi déclaré
dès le lendemain que les états unis
préféreraient diviser les pays entre
ceux qui sont selon eux bons et ceux qui
sont mauvais plutôt que de réduire et
supprimer les lignes de démarcation